Hi, I'm Stina.
Welcome to Iceland Academy.
In today's class, I'll be showing you how to practice safe selfies.
You see, even though Iceland has a scenery to die for,...
...it doesn't actually mean that you need to die for it.
We all love a good selfie and some go to great lengths to capture them,...
...but please don't take any risk by going out on slippery ledges.
I can assure you, you will still get lots of likes.
I know you want to look hot in a selfie,...
...but some hot springs and geysers can be over a hundred degrees Celsius,...
...so please admire from a distance.
Some beaches in Iceland are known for their unpredictable waves and strong current.
So, one minute you are Cara Delevingne, and the next you're Sarah never seen.
So, please watch out not being too close to the water.
It's really easy to take amazing selfies here in Iceland.
You don't even need a filter.
So please don't take any risks.
Follow local information, obey the signs and stay safe.
Oh, already got over 100 likes.